how to protect your recipe so I got a
great question from one of my YouTube
viewers I love you guys amazing me who
wrote in to say thanks so much for the
advice I have a seasoning what would be
the best way to protect the recipe and
start making money from it I don't want
to approach a company without protecting
my product please any advice I would
appreciate it thank you
so here's the thing okay you can't
really get a patent or copyright on a
recipe if you were inventing a new way
of cooking then you might be able to
patent it but again remember patent only
lasts for 20 years with recipes it's
typically a trade secret so if you look
at the the recipe fer for KFC Colonel
Sanders secret chicken recipe not many
people know that if you look at the the
coca-cola company right they've been
around for over a hundred years and not
many people know exactly how coca-cola
is made what those companies will do is
make people sign a nondisclosure
agreement so basically by you opening up
and telling somebody exactly how your
seasoning is made they have to sign a
nondisclosure agreement saying that they
won't share with anybody else that's the
best way to protect your recipe now will
a company sign that who knows if you're
trying to sell it to a big company
typically they don't like signing these
things I remember when I was in the
venture capital business and even now
when entrepreneurs are pushing with
their ideas I don't sign non-disclosure
agreements because I see too many deals
and there's too many people doing almost
the exact same thing you definitely want
to put it on for team members that you
bring on board so if you're bringing on
people to help you make this you don't
want them going and running with it to
start their own business to start their
own seasoning recipe right taking your
exact same one so you want them signing
on disclosure agreements and you can try
you could try with companies you could
travel suppliers you could try with
other people who you're trying to sell
us into but it's a hard sell for them
it's hard for them to want to say yes
I'll sign the non-disclosure agreement
you have to have something that makes
them say wow you know they tried your
your recipe you
seasoning like oh my god we need to have
this we need to sign the deal is the
best thing we've ever tried then they
might be willing to sign the
non-disclosure agreement but that really
is the best way to protect your idea is
to a non-disclosure agreement because
you can't patent or copyright a recipe
believe for those are watching like the
video thumbs up below leave a comment
let me know what you think ask me a
question below if you have thoughts in
this video leave it below and click on
my face to subscribe to the channel and
see more videos like this thank you guys
so much I'll see you soon